TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome to the
Glass Development Kit sneak
peek.
Come on.
This is cool.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'll be your developer
advocate for the next,
I don't know, forever.
You can reach me online at
google.com/+TimothyJordan,
because the conversation
doesn't need to end here.
Also check out
developers.google.com/glass/community.
You can find links to our
Stack Overflow tag, our issue
tracker, and we can
continue hanging out
even when we're not in a room,
because the internet is really
that cool.
We've got a lot to
talk about today.
Just a handful of things that we
need to do are up on the board
here.
We're going to talk
about the Glass platform.
We're going to talk about
the components, the building
blocks of Glassware.
We're going to
spend a little bit
time of asking the
question, what is the GDK?
But it's not that existential.
It's very clear and
straightforward.
And then we're going to look
at some development paradigms
or patterns for Glass.
Does it sound like fun?
All right.
So let's jump into it.
First off, I wanted to
say a note about Glass.
Glass is this really
cool thing, as we all
know in this room,
that gives us access
to the technology that we love
without getting in the way.
And that's very cool.
But what's even
cooler is that it's
a way to build services
for users that they
can use in a natural and
everyday way in their lives.
We knew this was awesome when
we started building the hardware
and software at Google.
We knew it was going to be
even cooler when you built
the things that we
knew you were going
to build on this platform.
But even more exciting is the
stuff that we couldn't even
have imagined that
you've started to build
and you're yet to build now
that you have access to the GDK
that really reaches these
users in their everyday lives
in a way you could never do
before Glass was available.
And that's the Glass platform.
You've been building on it using
the Google Mirror API, which
is a RESTful web-based API.
And those services
that you've built,
there's only a handful of them
that are available online.
And even though it's early
days, 83% of Glass users
have at least one of those third
party Glass services installed,
which is a huge number
for just a handful that
are available to them.
Now again, the Mirror API
is what you built these on.
And it's a cloud-based
API that allows
you to insert timeline cards,
respond to user notifications,
and do sharing from Glass.
You can do a lot
with the Mirror API,
but you've been asking for more.
And we knew we needed
to give you more.
That's why we built the GDK.
We talked about this at
this last Google I/O,
and we've been
building it since.
And we're going to tell you
all the details about today.
There are three
major things here
that you can do on Glass now
that you couldn't do before.
The first one is offline.
You can now build code that runs
on Glass so the user can use it
whether or not they're
connected to the internet.
And you can also get real
time immediate user response.
This is a Glassware
that's installed on Glass
and the user can
interact with, and it
doesn't need to do a
round trip to your service
in the cloud to be able to
respond to a user request.
And then, finally, deeper
access to hardware,
such as the Accelerometer
and the GPS.
Now these three things are cool.
Trust me.
They're very cool.
And we're going
to get into detail
about how these are
implemented in the GDK.
But before we get there,
I want to show you.
Should we do a demo right away?
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
This is Word Lens on Glass.
And I don't know if you've
had this happen to you,
but I've had it
quite a few times
where I'm in a foreign country
and there's a sign like this.
It's like that guy looks
like he's having so much fun.
I want to do that.
But maybe I should
read the sign first.
You think?
So typically what I'll do
is I'll have a travel book,
and I'll flip through
and try and translate.
Or if I happen to have a SIM
in my phone for that country,
I'll bring up Google
Translate, and I'm
trying to enter in the
foreign characters.
But on Glass, as you'll see,
it's a way cooler experience.
OK, Glass, translate this.
I'm just going to
look at the sign,
and through Glass I'm going
to see the translation.
Which is pretty cool, huh?
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you, Lisa.
And I now know that I'm not
going to jump off that cliff,
because I might
plummet to my death.
That would be bad.
So these demos,
I'm going to show
you quite a few more of them.
Remember, it's a cooler
experience on Glass
when you actually
try it on Glass.
And everybody in this
room will have a chance
to try to all of these
demos a little bit later.
But I want to show them to you
in the context of explaining
the GDK, so please bear with
me, even though it's little bit
more choppy and ressed
up on the screen.
Now Word Lens does each
of those three things
that you can now
do with the GDK.
It does offline processing.
All that translation
is happening directly
on Glass without any
internet communication.
You can switch languages.
I could translate from
Spanish to English, English
to Portuguese, quite a few
languages on Word Lens.
And I can do all of that and
switch all of those languages
immediately on Glass.
Then, last but not least,
is it's accessing the camera
and doing that overlay and
translation directly on Glass,
accessing that
hardware directly.
Pretty cool, huh?
OK.
Let's talk about the building
blocks of what makes Glassware.
These are our
Glassware components,
and there's three areas
that I'd like to talk about.
First are types, what
kind of Glassware
that you might want
to build, invocation,
this is how you
start the Glassware,
and elements, the
primary UI components
that are presented to the user.
With types-- and you'll
see all these listed there.
They're very simple
and straightforward,
like development on
Glass-- there's the GDK,
which we're introducing today
and you're learn all about
in the next however long
this takes, the Mirror API--
this is what you've already
been doing with the cloud-based
API-- and GDK+ Mirror.
You can, in fact, use
both of these in a dance
together for a single
user experience.
For invocation,
typically users are
going to start Glassware
via the OK Glass menu.
This is a top-level
voice menu that
can trigger your Glassware
either via the Mirror
API or the GDK.
Menu item on a timeline card, so
you can interact with Glassware
and even start up
a GDK Glassware
from the menu item on a
timeline card and timeline cards
themselves, which are
inserted from the Mirror API.
Then there's these elements.
Let's actually dive deeper
into these elements.
This is kind of
what they look like.
The first one, live
card, this is something
that you couldn't do on
Glass with the Mirror API
but you can now do with the GDK.
Now this is something that
gives developers the ability
to draw directly into the
Glass timeline in real time.
And the reason I chose
that particular example
is that this is
stopwatch running
on Glass with millisecond
updates on Glass.
So you can actually see
that stopwatch count up,
and you can scroll through Glass
to other parts of your timeline
and scroll back, and that
card is still updating.
Static cards, which you already
know from the Mirror API.
This is a moment
in time that you
insert into the
user's Glass timeline.
It has a timestamp,
and it can interact
with that card via
the menu items.
Immersions, this is another
new thing with the GDK today.
This is a focused
user experience
where the rest of the Glass
UX kind of fades away,
and they're focused on
just doing that task.
You saw that with Word
Lens a moment ago,
and I'll give you more examples.
And then background services.
Background services are web
services or GDK services
that every once
in a while show up
with timeline cards or
live cards or immersions.
Let's look at an
actual flow here.
This is a live card flow,
which you would typically
start with an OK,
Glass voice command.
It'll start up a
Glassware service.
This is an Android service
that creates the live card
and inserts it into
the Glass timeline.
Live cards appear
to the left of Home.
Your Home is your
clock, and to the right
is everything that's sort
of fading into the past
on your timeline, your
history if you will.
And to the left is everything
that's happening right now
or is about to happen.
That includes live cards.
Static cards are inserted
into the Glass timeline,
and they appear to the right
of Home, as you'd expect
and as you already know
from using the Mirror API.
Now immersions, you start
with a voice command,
and they take over the
Glass user experience.
Unlike live cards where
if you swipe forward
you go to the next
card in the timeline,
immersions if you swipe
forward that's captured
by that experience and maybe
used by that Glassware.
So those gestures can be used
as part of the user experience.
Then, finally, services.
And again, these are
background services.
Most Mirror API Glassware are
services and something that's
running on the cloud constantly
and every once in a while
throws a timeline card your way.
You can also run GDK
Glassware as a service,
and it will show up maybe
with a live card or perhaps
an immersion when it's important
to the user for it to do so.
OK.
Those are building blocks.
And I'm going to
describe each of these
a little bit more later when we
get into the demos, more demos.
But first, let's take a
step back and say, well,
what is this GDK thing?
The GDK is super
straightforward and simple.
We worked really
hard to make sure
that if you're an Android
developer developing for Glass
would feel natural.
It uses the same paradigms
that you're already used to.
So we built the GDK with
standard Android APIs compiled
for Glass so that when you use
those Android APIs on Glass
it gives you the experience
that it should on Glass.
And I'll describe some of
those in detail in a moment.
For procedures
specific to Glass,
we have a simple
add-on that you add
into your already standard
Android development environment
and gives you access to
those specific features,
things like the live card or
the voice invocation commands.
All right.
Let's look at both those
lists in a bit more detail.
The platform features are things
like the Location Provider.
Now those of you that have
experienced directions
on Glass, you know
that you need Glass
tethered with your
Android phone,
because Glass uses the
GPS from the phone.
This complexity is
completely abstracted
away when you're
building with the GDK.
You use the normal
Location Provider,
like you would on any
other Android device,
and location will just
work when the user has
that Android phone tethered.
The camera intent also works
like it should on an Android
device, but it'll
use the Glass camera.
The recognizer
intent will start up
the Glass-specific
speech-to-text UX.
And then the Options menu,
it's just an Options menu
like you would have on Android.
Only on Glass, it will
render a Glass-specific menu.
The add-on features,
these are new things.
And you use the
add-on to get these.
It's a voice trigger-- which
allows you to insert commands
into the OK Glass menu--
gesture detection--
so as you're moving
around on the touch pad,
you can capture those gestures--
cards and card scroller-- which
will allow you to
build timeline cards
and arrange them on a mini
timeline in your Glassware,
so the users can scroll through
them like a Glass timeline--
and then live cards.
Live cards are that way
that you can draw directly
into the Glass timeline.
With all these features,
you can build the same level
of Glassware that's already
built into some of the system
Glassware, such as Directions.
But we also think
that you're going
to build a lot of new
and interesting stuff.
When users install
these Glassware,
they go to MyGlass like normal,
and they hit that On button.
And the APK is downloaded
to their Glass device.
And it'll look like
this to the user.
They'll see that card.
They hit that On switch.
Then on Glass, they
see a live card
to the left of Home saying
Activating this Glassware.
In this case, the
example is Word Lens.
And as soon as the
entire APK is downloaded,
that card moves
into the timeline,
and it says Activated.
Really simple flow for users.
For Glassware that needs
authentication of an account--
and this will be released soon.
We're still hammering
out a few details,
but it'll come out when
there's the full developer
preview-- the user goes through
the normal install flow,
but they're also given a
pop-up window to your web page
where they sign in.
Then you JSON encode an Android
Account Manager account,
send that to a Google
API, and then Google
will send that to
the user's Glass.
So when they run the
Glassware on Glass,
the Account Manager is already
populated with that account.
The GDK has all these
features, and we're
adding more all the time.
What's going to be
released is a sneak peek.
Next up is the
developer preview where
we'll get things like OAuth
and even more features,
hopefully based on a
lot of your feedback.
OK.
Now I want to give you
some really solid use cases
and examples of great Glassware.
And I'd like to do so
sort of in the perspective
of these development patterns.
There's about four
that we see developers
using to build Glassware.
And the first two you're already
doing with the Mirror API.
One of these is
periodic notifications.
You have a service in the cloud,
and every once in a while you
want to tell the user something.
So you send them
a timeline card.
Another one is sharing.
The user has an image on Glass
and they want to share it out
to a Google+ circle and they
share that again with a Mirror
API Glassware.
The ones that I'm going
to dive deeper into
are the GDK patterns
that you can do now
but you couldn't do with Glass
before the GDK was available.
One of those is ongoing tasks.
The user's doing
something, and they
want to frequently look
back at that ongoing task,
either for information
or interact.
The other one is immersion.
Immersion is when the
user has a focused task.
They want to stop
what they're doing,
focus on this task
for a little while,
and then when they
exit back they're
back at their normal
Glass experience.
For ongoing tasks, what
I'd like to show you--
And for all these
partners, they've
done an incredible job
of testing this API
and finding our bugs
and really getting
it ready for you to play with.
But they also have really
cool Glassware, Glassware
that I've enjoyed
using every day
and we think you're
going to love too.
One of those is Strava.
Strava is a great service
built for athletes
that helps you track
your runs and your rides.
I don't know about you, but
I use Strava every time I'm
on my bike.
But I do find it kind of
annoying and difficult
to get my phone out
of whatever pocket
I've decided to stash it in.
And when I'm riding, I still
want the benefits of Strava
and I want to get that coaching
and I want to see that data,
but I want to keep my
hands on the handlebars
and keep focused on my path
and the experience of riding
my bike.
That's why I'm out there.
With Strava on Glass, you
just speak to start tracking.
You just look up to see
the information that
matters to you.
And you can see your
personal records
relative to your best times
all by just looking up.
Shall we take a look at this?
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
I'm spoofing
location on a tablet
here so that it thinks that
I'm out there riding my bike.
It works pretty well.
We'll see how it looks.
OK, Glass, start a bike ride.
And there I am.
Ooh, I'm going fast.
That's great.
The wind must be at my back.
The great thing about
this is a couple things.
All I did was say, OK,
Glass, start a bike ride,
and it started.
There were no settings.
There were no
things to navigate.
I wasn't looking for the app.
It happened for me.
And that's the Glass experience.
Also, Glass went to standby.
But if I want, I just
look up, and there's all
my Strava information.
It's pretty cool, right?
And let's say if
I tap, you can see
that I can go through
my Segment History.
Those of you who use
Strava every day,
you know they have
these cool segments.
And one of the
things I like to do
is if I know where the
segment is I ride faster,
because that's the
thing that gets recorded
and I can share with my friends.
And typically, I
just sort of have
to know where that segment is.
Well, with Strava on
Glass, it tells me
as I just start the
segment, about halfway
through, and near
the end as well so
that I'm really
charging as fast as I
can so I can get that good time.
And then as I pass
through the segments,
it will load up Segment
History with what I've passed.
And as the segment's
ongoing, it'll
create an additional live
card, like this one right here.
That was good timing.
This is Hawk Hill, which is a
great climb in San Francisco.
I have not done
it in six minutes.
But maybe today I will
when I have pretend GPS.
I can look at this,
and it's giving me
my progress on this segment.
Anyway, I'm going to go back
to the Strava experience here.
I'm going to tap and hit Finish.
It saved the ride, and
it's uploaded to Strava.
And I can share it
with my friends later.
Pretty cool, huh?
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
I just showed you the demo.
I want to now look at the
flow just on a static page
here and describe some
of the platform features
that Strava is using
to make this happen.
The voice command is
invoked by the user,
and then this live
card is created.
Now you'll notice that Strava
looks like a Glassware.
It looks like the rest
of the Glass experience.
It's consistent, and it's
familiar with the user.
And that's because theming
is built into the SDK.
So all of those minor
implementation details
around colors and
fonts, you just
get that free with the GDK.
Also, they're using live
cards to draw directly
into the timeline,
which means that time
is ticking as you would expect.
I can zoom around that
timeline, I can zoom out,
and that live card
is still going.
It's directly rendering
into my timeline.
Then Strava is also
using authentication.
To start this up, I use
the flow that I mentioned
before where I clicked On, I
signed into my Strava account,
that account got
sent down to Glass,
and then Strava just used
it using the normal Android
Account Manager.
All right.
Let me show you another one.
And I'm going to need some
more GPS spoofing for this.
This is GolfSight by SkyDroid.
Golf is another
one of those things
that I like to do where I do
not want technology in the way,
but I still want
the benefits of it.
For example, when
I'm choosing my club,
I want to kind of how
far I am to the green.
And that changes, as you
know, because you hit,
and then you're in the fairway.
Or in my case, you're
usually off to the right,
and I'm not sure how
far I am to the green.
But with GolfSight,
I'll always know
how far I am both to
the front, middle,
and the back of the green, the
hazards that are on the course,
and all of that
just by looking up.
You want to see it?
OK.
Let me just go ahead
and say, OK, Glass,
start a round of golf.
It's going to find a
nearby golf courses.
And SkyDroid is so great.
Even though I'm spoofing my
GPS and it's not working well,
I can just select
the park that I want,
which is Golden Gate
Park golf course.
And it's going to load it up.
There I am.
There we are, 149
yards to the hole.
And you'll notice this hole is a
par 3, which is my skill level,
and I'd probably still hit a 5.
And if I want, I can just tap
on this card and maybe swipe
over to the hazards and targets.
I know there's a bunker
just the right of the green.
All this information I get
while I'm on the course
without breaking my stride.
And it's never in the way
when I don't want it to be.
Once I get to that green,
and with a little bit
of wishful thinking--
Let's say birdie, shall we?
Let's pretend.
It can be whatever I want.
And now I'm on to
the second hole.
Super simple.
But everything that
I otherwise would
have been like
ruffling in my bag
or like, nah, maybe in
the middle of the fairway
it knows, because it has
access to my location,
and it's giving me
that information
exactly when I need it.
Let's go ahead and end
this round, and we're done.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
That's GolfSight.
Again, let me take a moment
to talk about the GDK features
that GolfSight by
SkyDroid is using.
There's voice invocation,
and then I select the course.
And it lands on this page,
where I've got an Options menu.
This Options menu is your
Android Options menu.
But when it's rendered on
Glass, it's a Glass menu.
That's that second row there.
Also, they are using the
live card, like Strava,
and the Location Provider.
They're accessing GPS
all throughout my game
to know exactly where
I am, and they're
doing this like
normal on Android
with the Location Provider.
OK.
Let's talk about this next
pattern, which is immersion.
This is really new for Glass.
It's when the user wants to have
a focused task in front of them
where the rest of the
UI kind of fades away.
And a great example
of this game play.
The
New form factors always open
up incredible possibilities
for game play.
And our friends at Glu
built this really cool game
Spellista.
One of my favorite things about
this is the natural interface.
It allows me to play this
game completely hands-free.
Shall we take a look?
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [LAUGHS] OK.
OK, Glass, play a game.
I love how simple that is.
Here we are in Spellista.
It's a word jumble
game, and I'm playing
the level Under the Sea.
I'm terrible at it, but Jeff in
the front row is really good.
What is this?
JEFF: Turtles.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Oh, he's so good.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Turtles.
Is it L-E or E-L?
JEFF: L-E.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Turtles.
Yay.
I win.
That's so cool.
JEFF: Crabs.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Crabs?
OK.
You guys don't mind if I just
play this for a little while,
do you?
That is fun.
So super simple and easy.
And I love playing this
just about any time
during my day,
because it's always
right there whenever I want it.
Another cool thing about this
game is-- that was dolphins,
I know-- they built this
really cool feature that
lets me build my
own levels, and I
can share them with my friends.
And Lian built this Red
Sox Nation, go figure,
level that I can play.
She actually took
a picture on Glass
and then spoke some words
aloud, and that just
created the level.
And she could send
it to me, again,
from Glass, which
is a really cool way
to stay in touch with
your friends and family
when you're far away.
AUDIENCE: New York.
AUDIENCE: Boston.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Somebody said New York,
and I don't think it is.
I wonder what the next one is.
Again, very simple
and intuitive.
And the interface
is just delightful,
the way the scene moves
around as I look around.
It's really glanceable and
still feels very Glass-like.
All right.
Let's look at some of
the tools from the GDK
that Glu used to
build Spellista.
It's the voice invocation,
like before, only this voice
invocation then creates
an Android activity.
That Android activity
is the immersion.
It's just your normal
Android activity,
but on Glass it
creates that immersion.
Then Spellista is using a
couple really cool things here.
You notice that first row uses
sort of that rich imagery that
represents the levels.
They're using the cards
class to build those cards,
and they're using the
card scroller class
to make this feel like a
natural Glass timeline.
They're also using
the gyroscope.
And they're using the
gyroscope like normal,
like you would on any
other Android device,
except now it's me moving
my head in this natural way.
OK.
Another immersion
example is Word Lens.
I've already showed the
demo, so let me just
give you the details.
Word Lens has this really cool
real time translation overlay.
But on Glass, I
think you saw, it's
really what makes it come alive.
All I need to do is look at
the text I want translated,
and through Glass
I see it translate
into my natural language.
And I think the
cool thing that I
want to mention about Word
Lens is once I invoke it
it immediately uses the camera
and accesses that camera
feed directly.
It does some optical character
recognition using the NDK
on Glass, like you would on
any other Android device.
It computes the translation
and overlays that on the video
and shows that back to me.
They're also using the
gyroscope, so whenever it knows
I'm looking at something that's
when it starts translating it.
Again, it uses these
features of the GDK
that are really straightforward
Android paradigms but now
makes it a Glass-specific,
natural experience.
All right.
One more demo?
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [LAUGHS]
One more demo, Allthecooks.
Allthecooks is a social cooking
app for Android and iPhone,
and it is really cool.
I found with using
Allthecooks I'm
cooking more, because
recipes are there.
But also I'm doing
something that I never
did before because of
Allthecooks on Glass.
I'm actually taking pictures and
recording notes on my recipes
and sending them to my friends.
I never did this before
because it was always
kind of in the way.
You've got to get the
camera and the notepad.
I'm like, I need a better
shot, and then it's burnt.
It's just sort of an
awkward experience.
But cooking, you
really need your hands,
and that's where Glass
really shines in this case.
OK, Glass, find a recipe.
Oops.
Avocado.
I did the old cover the
microphone trick for-- there
we are-- the live demo that
works great the first time.
Allthecooks is now searching
for avocado recipes
on the internet, and I get
some really cool pictures here.
I'm going to scroll over back
and choose avocado relish,
and here's my recipe.
I can swipe forward and back
through these recipe steps.
And again, I can follow
the steps hands-free.
If ever I forget how
many avocados or onions,
I just look up, and there's
my ingredients list.
It's really nice.
It's simple.
It's intuitive.
It's that natural user
interface you'd expect on Glass.
And I don't know about you,
but usually when I'm cooking
it takes a long
time because I've
got to try things two or three
times before I get it right.
With Allthecooks on Glass,
they also insert a live card
so I can get back to that
experience easily on my Glass
timeline whenever I want.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Let's take a look at this again
and the GDK implementation
details that they used to
make this experience happen.
Allthecooks is using
cards and card scroller.
When it created those
recipes and they were bundles
and you tapped into them and
you were able to drill down,
all that is building
with the cards class
and using the card scroller
to keep that natural timeline
interface that you'd
expect on Glass.
They're also using
the RecognizerIntent.
Now this, again, is the
RecognizerIntent from Android.
But on Glass when you
run it, it gives you
the Glass-specific
speech-to-text interface.
OK.
Those patterns were periodic
notifications and sharing,
which you already do
on the Mirror API.
And the new ones that are
possible today with the GDK
are ongoing task and immersion.
All of these partners that
we've been working with,
again they've done a
great job of helping
us test the platform.
But also, I've really loved
using these Glassware on Glass
day in and day out, and
we think you will too.
All of these will be available
on my Glass later today.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
we have a couple
more simple Glassware that
we're throwing on there,
the compass and the
stopwatch, both GDK Glassware
that we built and open sourced.
They're going to be available
on the documentation for you
to learn how to use
the GDK even quicker.
And the Mirror API
has been going strong,
and more people have been
submitting their Glassware
for review.
Three more just got
available and are
going to be launching today as
well, Umano, which allows you
to get trendy news articles
on Glass read to you
by professional voice actors,
so you can get your news while
still on the go, and
Jewish Guide for Glass.
Let's say you're
traveling in a local place
and you need some kosher food.
You can set a reminder
on Jewish Guide,
and it will come up at lunch
time with all the kosher
restaurants nearby.
And If This Then That.
If This Then That has
a ton of cool recipes
that you can use now with Glass.
Say, for example, you're
looking for an apartment
in San Francisco.
You can use If This Then
That to get notified
as soon as a new listing
is posted on Craigslist.
All this stuff is
going to be available
later today on my Glass, and
it joins a lot of the Glassware
that's already up there.
It's just a handful of Glassware
that we have on my Glass,
because we're just
getting started.
And even so, we've been
delighted and surprised
by the cool new things that
people want to do with Glass.
But today, now that
the GDK's available,
more than ever
we're excited to see
what you will do next, both
the things that we know you're
going to do with this that
are great use cases on Glass
and the things that we
haven't even thought of yet.
Because one thing we know about
our Explorer community is you
guys dream really
big, and we can't
wait to see how you make those
dreams tangible with the Glass
Development Kit.
Let's take a quick look
at the walk-through,
just so you know how easy it is
to get started with the Glass
Development Kit.
Again, I keep saying this is
Android development that you're
used to.
Let's go ahead and load
up Eclipse with ADT.
Now this is pretty much fresh
install on my computer here.
Remember, there was
the part of the GDK
that's built into
the platform on Glass
using normal Android
platform APIs,
but they'll just work on
Glass the way they should.
And then there's
the add-on library
that gives you deeper access
to the Glass-specific features.
You need to get that add-on
library before you start
building on the GDK, and it's
available through the SDK
Manager.
Now I've already gone
ahead and installed it.
It's this item right here.
You look under API
Level 15, and you'll
see Glass Development
Kit Sneak Peek.
You click on that, install
the package, read the license,
accept the terms, and then come
back to your Eclipse interface.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a new sample
project from the add-on.
So I'm just going to
go to File, New, Other.
And I'm going to choose
Android Sample Project
and select the Glass
Development Kit.
Let's try the stopwatch.
OK.
I've got the stopwatch
here, and I'm
going to choose-- I don't know.
Let's just run it,
see what happens.
Choose my Glass
device and click OK.
Now I might have another
stopwatch APK here,
but it just compiled it.
And now it's installing it.
And it's done.
Cool.
Let's take a look
at my Glass device.
OK, Glass, start a stopwatch.
[LAUGHS] And there it is.
From installing Eclipse to on
Glass in-- what was that?--
a minute?
Two minutes?
That's the GDK.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
The GDK and the documentation
are right now a sneak peek.
That means the full developer
preview is coming later.
But we still wanted
to give it to you guys
to get your hands on it so you
could test it, find some bugs,
and also find the stuff
that's missing that you really
want to really be able
to make great Glassware.
We're making it available as
this sneak peek later today.
And you'll find the instructions
for getting the add-on and all
the documentation at
developers.google.com/glass.
Now we are just getting started,
and we do want that feedback.
We want to build this
platform with you.
So please just add
a slash community
on the end of that
URL, and you'll
come to links for our
Stack Overflow tag
as well as our Issue Tracker.
We really want to hear
from you about how
we can make this platform great.
Then, finally,
Android development.
The GDK is built on
the Android platform.
So you'll also want to take
a look at that documentation
to get started.
And again, what's
really going to happen
next is you get to build
Glassware using the Mirror API
and now with all these
new features that
are available to
the GDK the really
open up these
magical experiences
that let you build Glassware
that fit into people's lives
in a natural way.
A lot of the stuff that you saw
today wasn't available on Glass
before the GDK.
You just couldn't do that
kind of user experience.
But a lot of those demos
also, you may have noticed,
weren't possible before Glass.
There's something
about this form factor
that really opens up a
new realm of possibilities
for building great
user experiences
and solving real user problems.
And we can can't wait to see
you do just that with the GDK.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]